I think Obama gave a great speech on
race I could definitely relate to it
because you know coming from Haiti you
know you have like what's still called
the upper class and then what's
considered the lower class you know what
I'm saying and uh and sometimes you know
because someone from the upper class
makes it the lower class want to hate
and you say where the hell is this hate
coming from like why do they feel a
certain way well they feel that way
because there's nothing wrong with being
part of the upper class but they take it
back two generations or three
generations before and that hate is
coming from the fact of their saying
well our super super ancestors were
slaves you know and you know we
basically feel like we're in the same
position so a lot of times when you see
hate in the issue of race you got action
stuff we're actually is this hate coming
from no one is really making this hate
up like there was one time where people
is really getting lynched there was
really one time when there was sick and
dogs on people like this that's Martin
Luther King he got shot like this is for
real like there's a time where people
was angry you understand and similar to
Obama I mean what I feel is that
you know there's Moses right and then
Moses could go but so far and then Moses
look they said josh we'll go ahead
handle it so I feel like we're the Josh
was it today so I feel like being the
Joshua's that today we got to get past
the old situation and moving forward for
it to work we all have to feel like we
won race I don't know the last time you
check the economy they don't say okay
well you're not you losing your house
because you're white or you're not
losing your house because you're black
or because you're yellow no they're like
yo you can't pay for this house where
take we all in this thing together so we
need to get past this race issue and
start dealing with reality
I think the new generation of Joshua's
like we're not done but we need to start
and I think where we start at is
unifying and really being one and really
not waiting for things to be in a bad
position to really talk about it to
really understand that we're leaders you
can pick up a pen and write to Congress
you can email if you don't like certain
things from the beginning because there
is a real Constitution and they need to
spend respect the generation that's
coming up and that we're dealing with
that right now I think that's very
important that you exercise your rights
before something goes down and that's
when you feel like you want to deal with
it then people don't take you serious
because they're like oh you only you
only apply action when you feel it's
necessary well I feel that action is
necessary all the time there's so much
things that are going on the world from
Africa to Asia to back in your own home
town where you're right now you're
sitting in the community you might not
be happy with the community maybe you
don't want them to break that building
down right there because that building
represents a monument something for the
community well talk about it right to
the mayor you understand maybe you need
more funds for the school you don't like
the way this school is being treated you
look and you like well where's these
funds for education get together rally
with the kids and talk about this did
this this you have this is what we have
to do to start moving forward